marie claude bibeau ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'agroalimentaire
ottawa bonsoir madame bibeau bonsoir
alors 1500 $ par travailleur étranger en
subventions là en quelque sorte pour
subventionner les coûts de quarantaine
des travailleurs étrangers comment vous
êtes arrivé à ce montant alors on a
évalué les différents besoins et non
d'une part si la question de s'offrir
une résidence qui permet de respecter le
protocole d'isolement donc d'abord
toujours deux mètres de distance avec
ses colocataires entre les lis pas trop
de gens en méditant le partage la même
cuisine au lit même pièce commune
alors on sait que certains producteurs
soient présents ployant vont devoir
louer des chambres d'hôtel pour la
période d'isolement d'une part on sait
aussi que ça veut dire deux semaines de
salaire sans travail en contrepartie
alors après de longues discussions là
plusieurs discussions avec les gens de
l'industrie
on est arrivé à un montant de 1500
dollars le tout semblait raisonnable
pour tout le monde est-ce que vos
mesures vont permettre aux agriculteurs
d'avoir accès à tous les travailleurs
étrangers dont ils ont besoin
le défi était pas seulement financier
pour avoir accès aux travailleurs
étrangers c'est sûr que ça permet à
certains employeurs avec cette
subvention là de pouvoir avoir accès à
des logements qui répondent aux critères
du protocole visuellement mais encore
des défis à relever au niveau de la
logistique entre autres dans certains
pays comme au guatemala par exemple au
lieu des restrictions sur le transport à
l'intérieur du pays c'est difficile pour
nos travailleurs de se rendre à l'arrêt
ou pas même si on a l'autorisation
d'aller les chercher avec un vol nolisé
en fait que l'industrie peut aller
chercher donc il certains défis
logistiques qui restent à relever encore
dans certains pays
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas de tests quand
les gens arrivent ici a pas de tests en
arrivant au canada ils sont placés en
quarantaine pendant 14 jours ils doivent
s'isoler
vous avez dit un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui qu'on va vérifier les
symptômes au départ du mexique et du
guatemala
comment vous allez comme le canada peut
faire ça à l'avant le fait d'épargner
la procédure est un peu différente au
mexique par exemple on travaille
directement en collaboration avec le
ministère du travail au ministère de la
santé qui vont accueillir la les
travailleurs à leur départ à la rue par
la voix qui vont leur fournit toutes les
informations pertinentes à leur état de
santé et aussi aux règles qui doivent
suivre quand ils vont arriver au canada
au guatemala c'était un médecin qui est
reconnu par le gouvernement du canada
qui va accueillir les travailleurs là
bas qui va leur fournir toute
l'information aussi dans tous les cas
ils vont voyager avec un masque que les
gens vont prendre leur température avant
le départ s'assurer qu'ils ont créé
septembre vont voyager avec un masque on
va encore faire des vérifications à
l'arrivée et quand ils arrivent ici au
canada ils sont pris en charge par
différentes organisations qui vont les
amener à des transports privés vers leur
milieu où est ce qu'ils vont faire leur
résidence
il va avoir un suivi qui va être fait le
pendant les 14 jours au niveau de leur
état de santé
et si quelqu'un qui devait être malade
le système de santé canadien va prendre
en charge le travailleur la wii donc ces
mêmes procédures qui s'appliquerait en
temps normal si l'année passée un
travailleur avec une pneumonie il y aura
accès au système de santé
donc on suit les recommandations de la
santé publique sur la santé publique du
québec qui va assurer le suivi
ici au québec et les programmes sont
déjà prévus pour bosser et sur les
installations agricoles du québec et du
canada partout au pays est ce qu'il ya
un suivi serré qui est fait pour
s'assurer que tout est bien respectée
que toutes les normes qui sont exigés
notamment de 14 jours d'isolement sont
sont bel et bien respecté
oui lui d'abord des inspections à
différents niveaux qui vont
s'entrecroiser aussi dans d'une part au
niveau du ministère du travail pour
s'assurer que toutes les conditions à
respecter les normes et nos engagements
à l'égard de nos travailleurs
le ministère de du travail de
l'immigration aussi fait l'éducation et
à travers la sienne
donc on va au québe aussi formé suivi au
niveau de l'état de santé des
travailleurs alors il ya différentes
façons là pour assurer suit est donc là
on va aider justement employé des
travailleurs étrangers qui sont
essentiels dans le secteur agricole
mais compte tenu que des millions de
canadiens qui ont perdu leur emploi est
ce que vous pourriez soutenir aussi l'
embauche de travailleurs canadiens
actions déjà ici c'est ce qu'on les
encourage vraiment à se joindre aux
secteurs de l'alimentation
on est en train de travailler à
différents scénarios pour mettre en
place des incitatifs pour pour le
travail dans le secteur agricole
mais effectivement il ya toujours des
emplois disponibles le même quand on
reçoit 60 mille travailleurs étrangers
dans une terre agricole il reste encore
environ 15000 postes vacants alors
vraiment j'encourage déjà il ya eu des
appels dans les derniers jours en faveur
de la souveraineté alimentaire de
l'achat local également comment votre
gouvernement pour aider les agriculteurs
à produire plus plus longtemps dans
l'année pour augmenter la proportion de
fruits de légumes de viande qui sont
produits chez nous c'est sûr que c'est
une volonté qu'on a tous d'ailleurs j'ai
une très belle collaboration avec le
ministre de l'agriculture au québec
monsieur la montagne on regarde à
différentes options à chacun à notre
niveau
voir comment on peut justement
encourager l'achat local d'une part mais
la production aussi c'est sûr que les
défis sont assez importantes quand on
arrive au niveau de la transformation
transformation des aliments
transformation des viandes aussi les
abattoirs s'il ya un défi au niveau des
économies d'échelle et des trois
abattoirs qui offre des prêts qui sont
difficilement compétitif pour les plus
petits abattoirs donc c'est un défi sur
lequel on travaille
merci madame bibeau merci beaucoup merci
à vous